Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio Nummer 279. Ich wollte gerade sagen nach langer Zeit, aber das stimmt ja gar nicht, weil es gab ja gerade eine Folge, auch wenn das was ganz anderes war, aber eben jetzt mal wieder ein Chaosradio, was auch immer das bedeutet, das wird sich vielleicht in der Zukunft auch ändern. Anyways, heute sprechen wir wieder, wie wir das im Chaosradio so machen, über ein Thema, das irgendwie mit unserer digitalen Welt zu tun hat, wo irgendwie Dinge kaputt sind oder kaputt sein könnten oder dazu gebracht werden, dass man sie vielleicht kaputt machen kann und wie sich das mit uns, der Gesellschaft und der IT-Technologie alles sozusagen so zusammenschweißt oder auseinanderfällt, das werden wir alles sehen. Und es geht heute um etwas, was immer mal wieder so Thema ist, aber auf einer anderen Ebene, wie wir das sonst hier besprechen, es geht um einerseits irgendwas mit Gesundheit, irgendwas mit digital und dann, das ist der große Unterschied, heute im Hauptthema oder im Hauptfokus, muss man sagen, Europa. Wie das alles zusammenhängt, verrät uns jetzt unter anderem Bianca Kastel, deren Hauptberuf, habe ich mir sagen lassen, es ist Faxe aus dem Gesundheitswesen zu vertreiben. Oder man kann es, glaube ich, auch anders formulieren, sie ist Vorsitzende des Innovationsverbundes Öffentliche Gesundheit. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Kurze Frage, wie vertreibt man dann Faxe aus deinem Gesundheitssystem? Ach so. Und das geht? Ja, dazu kommen wir jetzt wahrscheinlich dann gleich auch. Außerdem die beiden CCC-Sprecherinnen Konz und Carlesi. Hallo und herzlich willkommen.
Ja, das ist wieder so eine Zuspitzung, die du immer machst. Okay, dann müssen wir über IT-Sicherheit eigentlich sprechen. Und welche Maßnahmen wir fordern würden. Die zusätzlich sind zu der Frage dieser Widerspruchsrechte. Denn egal, ob du opt in, opt out hast, oder aber gar keinen opt in, opt out, du hast es IT-sicherheitsmäßig so zu sichern, dass nicht Hintz und Kunz und seine Schwester ein Datenreichtum haben. Denn wir haben ja parallel auch eine IT-Sicherheitskrise. Und die drückt sich auch geradeaus in Fragen von gehackten Gesundheitsdaten. Und zu adressieren ist eigentlich, das hängt zusammen, aber es sind auch teilweise explizit andere Forderungen, die hier zu stellen sind.
Ich würde Willi Merkel gerne noch rein. Der Gesichtsausdruck war so wie, interessante Frage, aber ich weiß nicht so genau.
Also ich glaube, das ist das Grundproblem, was wir haben. Wir haben immer diese Universal-Lösungen, die wir immer so haben. Wir wollen technische Universal-Lösungen. Wir wollen irgendwie so die zentrale Datensammelstelle, weil die ist einfach und convenient. Ich glaube, wir haben für vieles, brauchen wir so den Möglichkeitenraum, den wir Leuten auch irgendwie bieten. Das ist bei Opt-in und Opt-out das Szenario. Also es gibt Menschen, die möchten, die sagen, ja macht mit deinen Daten, was ihr wollt. Ich habe dann den Universal-Zustimmung von mir. Und es gibt Menschen, die möchten sehr, sehr differenziert genau gucken, was sie machen möchten. Aber wir kriegen immer so diese, wir kriegen nur eine Lösung, wir müssen uns auf eine Lösung einigen, die soll für alles funktionieren. Das kann ja nicht funktionieren, weil Menschen sind ja auch in der Art und Weise, wie sie mit Gesundheitsdaten sich ausdrücken und artikulieren wollen, ganz anders. So ist es, glaube ich, auch bei der technischen Fragestellung. Also es gibt, glaube ich, für bestimmte Szenarien Lösungen für den Einzelfall, aber es gibt keine universelle für vieles. Und das ist, glaube ich, bei vielen Dingen, wo man das Gefühl, also im Gesundheitsthema gerade, so dieses, man will eine schnelle Lösung für alles machen, aber man muss anerkennen, dass es einfach so verschiedene Möglichkeiten für verschiedene Zwecke braucht. Und dass man manchmal auch sehr, sehr stark die Patientinnen mit einbeziehen muss und sie fragen muss, wie möchtest du das eigentlich? Folgende Risiken sind dabei, das sind die Chancen. Und wenn du nicht damit irgendwie zurecht kommst, werden wir das jetzt leider in technischen Tiefen nicht erklären können. Hier sind Empfehlungen von neutralen Organisationen zum Beispiel, die sagen, gut, wir haben uns das mal angeguckt. Technisches Risiko ist vertretbar bzw. gar nicht vertretbar. Das sind also so Mitteldinge auch immer. Also die Vorstellung, die immer kommt, ist, wenn du es so kompliziert machst mit dieser Mitbestimmung, dann versteht das ja kein Mensch mehr. Also machen wir das einfach für euch.
Ich habe noch eine Detailfrage. Und zwar, das klingt jetzt so ein bisschen so, als ob man nicht nur opt in, opt out, sondern auch opt in, aber dann mit. Ich habe noch eine Frage zu dieser Pseudonymisierung. Die Differential Privacy funktioniert doch nur, wenn da alle mitmachen. Oder geht das auch sozusagen, manche Daten werden, wie heißt das genannt, verrauscht? Manche Daten werden verrauscht und manche nicht. Geht das?
Nee, du willst das eigentlich über den Datenbestand machen, den du gerade nutzen willst.
Also das wäre kein Weg zu sagen, du kannst ganz einwirken oder du kannst sagen, ja, aber verrauscht.
Also wenn du Daten rausgibst, etwa an denen der nutzungsberechtigt ist, der einen Antrag gestellt hat und die Daten kriegt, der kriegt halt einen fetten Blob Daten, dann kannst du das Verfahren nutzen.
Die Frage war, ob wir sagen, also du schmeißt gerade zwei Sachen durcheinander. Oder ich bringe sie zusammen. Das könnte eine sehr schlechte Idee sein, weil man sollte seine Parlamentarier nicht unbeaufsichtigt lassen und sie sollte sie auch tunigst nicht auf solche Ideen bringen. Also ich verstehe.
Stopp, es war erstmal nur eine Frage, wie ist das technisch? Meine Frage ist eigentlich die, wenn ich einen Datensatz habe, wo verschiedene Menschen daran beteiligt sind, ist es dann technisch sinnhaft zu sagen, ein paar von denen verrauschen und ein paar nicht? Oder?
Also wenn wir von einem Konzept ausgehen, was wir auf Privacy by Design auslegen wollen, dann wollen wir das per Default komplett immer so machen. Da stellen wir auch gar nicht die Frage, ob nein oder ja.
Dann widersprichst du dir aber gerade, oder ihr widersprecht euch selber, aber ihr habt ja gerade gesagt, die Leute wollen verschiedene Auswahlmöglichkeiten haben. Dazu zählt auch, dass ich sage, bitte nehmt meine Daten und nehmt den Datensatz auch so konkret, wie es geht.
Okay, warte mal, dann müssen wir vielleicht nochmal kurz sagen, was ist der Sinn von Differential Privacy? Man muss sich mal klar machen, was das soll. Das ist ja eine von verschiedenen technischen Möglichkeiten, um dieses De-Anonymisieren möglichst wirksam zu erschweren. Das ist der Ziel von Differential Privacy. Also zu sagen, ich habe hier einen fetten Blob an Daten und ich kann nicht in anderen riesen Daten das dagegen laufen lassen, um Leute zu de-anonymisieren. Das ist ja der Zweck der Übung. Und ich glaube, deine Frage zählt auf etwas anderes, oder?
Ja.
Nee, meine Frage zählt darauf, in diesem Blob könnte es da auch Daten geben, die man de-anonymisieren kann oder welche, die man nicht de-anonymisieren kann.
Also die Argumentationskette von Markus ist, für Forscher ist ja sozusagen, je mehr sie wissen über die Personen, desto besser. Und je genauer die Daten sind, desto besser. Und wenn wir über Opt-in sprechen, ob es sinnvoll möglich ist, zu sagen, ich mache ein generelles Opt-in, aber auch ein Opt-in dafür, dass sozusagen in Klarnahmens-Manier meine Daten übermittelt werden, weil das ja besser ist für die Forschung. Also sozusagen eine Datenspende in großen Anführungszeiten.
Na gut, sowas gibt es natürlich heute auch. Es gibt ja viele Forscher, die gerade bei seitenden Krankheiten oder spezifischen Krankheiten auch heute Patienten explizit fragen. Dann sind das auch nicht pseudonymisierte Daten. Das gibt es ja.
Aber das kann man nicht zusammen... Also die Frage ist...
Ich glaube, ich erkläre meine Frage anscheinend nicht gut genug. Vielleicht bin ich auch schon zu lange hier beim Chaosradio dabei. Meine Frage ist folgendes. Es gibt, ich mach das mal ganz konkret, es gibt 50 Leute. 50 Leute haben ihre Datensätze. Diese Datensätze werden pseudonymisiert. Und jetzt von dem, was ich von Bianca verstanden habe, ist folgendes. Wenn ich diese Datensätze verrausche, dann wird es schwieriger, aus diesen 50 Leuten auf die konkreten 51 Personen zurückzukommen.
Das sollte unmöglich sein sogar.
Okay, so. Jetzt meine Frage folgende. Es gibt diesen Datensatz, und das verrauschen hab ich so verstanden, die einzelnen Datensätze werden verrauscht. Es gibt von diesen 50 Leuten 25, die sagen, wir wollen es verrauschen. Und die anderen 25 sagen, wir wollen es nicht.
Ach so, du willst die Leute spezifisch fragen. Du musst ihnen vorher erklären, was Differential Privacy ist.
Genau. Und meine Frage ist jetzt, sinkt dadurch der Pseudonymisierungsschutz für die 25, die verrauschen wollen? Weil die Gesamtmenge der Verrauschung kleiner wird.
Dann ist deine Frage eigentlich nach der Skalierbarkeit. Differential Privacy hat zu tun mit der Menge der Daten. Die Güte der Verrauschung hat mit der Menge der Daten zu tun. Aber du willst nicht ernsthaft... Aber der Hintergrund der Frage ist, du möchtest Menschen, glaube ich, schon jahrelang so krank sind. Willst du die wirklich mit einfachen Fragen beschäftigen? Du willst doch nicht jemand, der gerade eine Krankenschichte hat, mit wirklich technisch anspruchsvollen Fragen irgendwie belästigen.
Stopp, ich hatte euch so verstanden, dass das ein Ziel ist.
Nein, nein, nein.
Stopp, Bianca, ich hatte dich so verstanden.
Andersrum, ich muss noch mal erklären, wie das in der Praxis funktionieren können soll. Es gibt ja so diese einfachen Fragen, warum möchtest du Forschung? Ja, nein. Aber das ist ja keine Ja-Nein-Frage, sondern es sind verschiedene Stufen, die man begehen kann. Also es gibt so diese, Daten sind anonym, weil es sind zum Beispiel, die sind nur in Hunderterstücken irgendwie in Kohorten zusammengefasst. Da kann man dann davon ausgehen... Also irgendwie Menschen im Alter von 50 bis 55, die alle irgendwie, weiß nicht, eine bestimmte Krankheit haben und so, die in der Summe halt irgendwie eine Eigenschaft haben. Da ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du die Leute dann mit... Das kann man auch irgendwie durchrechnen, wenn man so viele Parameter dazu macht, relativ gering, dass du daraus irgendwie Menschen wiederfinden kannst. Gehen wir mal davon aus, dass die Daten tatsächlich anonym sind. Da kann man ja sagen, Anonymität, Vorstand an Anonymitat finde ich total super, habe ich nichts dagegen, bin ich dafür. So, dann kann ja sein, dass man feststellt, ok, jetzt brauchen wir Absurdium mit Daten. Dann kann man jetzt zum Beispiel dann überlegen, ok, gibt es denn eine Möglichkeit, bei der es die Möglichkeit gibt, dass man, also zum Beispiel möchte ich KI-Vorschriften auf meinen Daten haben, weil dann irgendwelche großen Modelle trainiert werden und irgendwie eine Million Daten zusammengefasst werden und daraus irgendwelche Dinge gefolgt werden. Dann kann man sagen, möchte ich, ja, nein. Dann kann man tatsächlich auch in verschiedene Dinge gehen, wie, also möchte ich die Daten wirklich in der reinen Form rausgehen oder möchte ich so noch verrauscht rausgeben, das kann man natürlich so unterteilen. Das Ganze funktioniert natürlich bei Differential Privacy und bei anderen Verfahren halt immer nur so bedingt, weil man dann feststellen wird, ok, man kann jetzt nicht beliebig Dinge miteinander kombinieren. Man kann es nicht irgendwie die Anonymen kombinieren mit den Differential Privacy Nein-Dingern und so, sondern muss dann schon sehr, sehr quasi unterteilen, wie viel Daten sind eigentlich von denen, die dann noch zustimmen, über.
Das heißt, es macht keinen Sinn, sich Modelle auszudenken, wo es eine Abstufung gibt?
Naja, doch, würde ich schon sagen, denn ich betrachte diese Methoden, von denen Differential Privacy nur eine ist, tatsächlich als Teil eines Straußes von Methoden. Und du wirst dir überlegen müssen, für welche Anwendungsfälle ist welche Technik die besser? Du kannst nicht alles mit einer erschlagen.
Aber das sollen sich die Gesetzgeber überlegen, nicht die Patienten.
Ich glaube nicht, dass man ihnen das erklären kann.
Jetzt kommt man wieder zu dieser Forderung, die ich vorhin aufgestellt habe, zurück. Wenn wir Digitalisierung machen und wir die Convenience haben wollen, müssen wir sie trotzdem so machen, dass alle informationelle Selbstbestimmung ausüben kann. Und wenn ich jetzt anfange, Patientinnen die unterschiedlichen Prinzipien von Pseudonymisierung und die unterschiedlichen Abstufungen und die unterschiedlichen Vor- und Nachteile davon zu erklären, dann wird es schwierig.
Ich hätte das wirklich auch für praktisch Quatsch.
Das heißt, das Ziel ist schon, man muss pro Fall oder pro Kategorie im Gesetzgebungsverfahren herausgearbeitet werden, was da die gute Lösung ist. Für die Patientinnen geht es letztlich nur ums Opt-in.
Irgendwas hat jetzt an technischen Kriterien festgestellt, aber in der Realwelt gibt es noch andere Forderungen. Manche sagen, ich habe nichts dagegen, wenn das eine universitäre Forschung ist. Andere sagen, wenn da irgendwelche Tech-Konzerne beteiligt sind, dann will ich es nicht mehr. Das ist sehr unterschiedlich, wie der Wunsch ist von Patienten. Manche sagen, wenn das Forschung für gesunde Kinder oder gegen Diabetes ist, dann ja. Die haben ganz andere Kategorien, die sind eher semantisch. Wir haben jetzt technische Kategorien.
Ich bin jetzt verwirrt, weil ich höre sozusagen, ich glaube, im Zehn-Minuten-Takt wechselseitig, die Patienten müssen nur Ja oder Nein sagen und die Patienten brauchen eine reichhaltige Auswahl.
What is it? Also zu diesem EU-Gesetz wird es auch ein technisches Implementierungswerk geben. Das heißt, in dem EU-Gesetz wird drin stehen, also jetzt als ganz plattes Beispiel, als Patientin habe ich das Recht, zuzustimmen oder darüber zu entscheiden, ob meine Daten für den europäischen Datenraum, nennen wir ihn jetzt einfach mal, verwendet werden.
Das wäre ein einfaches Opt-in.
Das wäre ein einfaches Opt-in. Und dann gibt es natürlich die Regelung zu dem europäischen Datenraum, also zu dieser sekundären Nutzung, die ja dann nochmal anders aussehen kann. So, und dann, also das wäre sozusagen das einfachste Szenario. Und dann hast du natürlich dieses Ja oder Nein. Was Konstanze jetzt aber angesprochen hat, ist natürlich, dass die Gemengelage viel komplexer ist. Also wenn wir jetzt irgendwie annehmen, dass dieser europäische Datenraum wirklich nur für universitäre Forschung genutzt würde.
Was nicht so sein wird.
Was nicht so sein wird, aber wenn das jetzt so wäre, dann wäre es ja auch relativ einfach, diese Frage zu beantworten. Weil ich dann weiß, okay, das wird nur für universitäre Forschung genutzt. Ich bin eigentlich grundsätzlich damit einverstanden. Aber das ist halt nicht die Gemengelage. Und das wird halt auch ganz schwierig sein. Das wird, glaube ich, in der Sekundärnutzung, da wird, Bianca mir sicherlich zustimmen, eine sehr interessante Frage sein, wer wie unter welchen Bedingungen Zugriff auf die Daten bekommt. Aber das ist eine Frage, die nochmal separiert ist.
Die haben wir eigentlich noch gar nicht besprochen. Ich halte mal kurz fest, du hast die Sache hier verkompliziert, nicht wir. Also schonmal nur mal um die Klarheit zu machen.
Ich stelle hier nur sozusagen am Auftrag der Hörerinnen, die ja sozusagen später vielleicht entscheiden sollen können oder nicht, worüber sie entscheiden sollen können oder nicht. Und das ist ja auch hier wieder die Frage in der Sekundärmarkt, sagt ja, okay, also die Verwendung der Daten ist halt abhängig davon, wer dann einen Zugriff hat. Und das ist ja meine Frage wieder. Knüpft ihr eine politische Forderung daran, dass in dem Gesetz steht, wer darauf Zugriff hat, habt ihr da eine Präferenz oder ist das was, wo ihr sagt, nee, da müssen die Leute auch sagen können, wem sie ihre Daten zur Verfügung stellen wollen.
Na, dann sollten wir das mal konkret machen. Wir machen es mal in der deutschen Situation, wo es ja anders als im europäischen Raum schon feststeht. Also in Deutschland ist es so, dass es Nutzungsberechtigte geben kann, die einen Antrag stellen müssen, an die Daten zu kommen. Dann legen die auch gewisse plausible Daten da. Und daher kann man natürlich auch sofort politische Forderungen reingnüpfen, nämlich wie das Entscheidungsgremium, was über diese ja-nein Nutzungsberechtigten ja oder nein sagt, wie besetzt ist etwa. Also wer soll da konkret drin sitzen? Wie viel unabhängig wir davon sein müssen? Wie wir dürfen zum industriell-pharmatischen Komplex gehören? Welche sollten vielleicht, weiß ich nicht, Ethiker sein? Das sind ja viele ethische Fragen.
Also da ist die Lösung, das sollen nicht die einzelnen Personen machen, die davon betroffen sind im Zweifelsfall, sondern da soll es ein Kontrollgremium geben, was unabhängig ist.
Das gibt es ja schon, aber wie besetzt wird dann zum Beispiel eine politische Forderung? Wie soll besetzt sein? Und wer ist da kategorisch raus?
Aber das muss das auch okay für euch. Der Markt wird über ein Kontrollgremium entschieden.
Du musst das ja irgendwie praktisch machen. Du hast irgendwie den Datenblub und irgendwer muss mit Daten rankommen. Dafür musst du einmal den Zugriff geben, aber du musst natürlich auch entscheiden, was fällt das unter die Regelungen, die in meinem Gesetz steht, dieser Antrag zum Beispiel? Und ist das eine Institution, die in der Liste der Institutionen, die nutzungsprächtig sind, dabei ist?
Ja, aber allein dieses Ding sozusagen, es gibt die Daten für die Sekundärnutzung und da gibt es ein Kontrollgremium. Das als Konzept ist schon okay für euch?
Ja, ich denke, das ist für eine praktische, sinnvolle Lösung. Ich fände das natürlich nicht sinnvoll, wenn jetzt nun die Tech-Konzerne und die kommerziellen Forschungsfraktionen sich die Klinke in die Hand geben, die können natürlich eine Besetzung ordentlich...
Und die Frage ist dann auch wieder, wie die Daten dahingekommen sind und dann darüber entschieden wurden.
Da weiß ich jetzt praktisch in Deutschland, er sagt nichts drüber.
Genau, aber...
Ich hänge ja die ganze Zeit am Kopf an diesem grundsätzlichen Problem. Als einzelner Mensch sozusagen, wie entscheide ich über meine Daten? Ich lerne jetzt also, es soll für mich als Einzelmenschen, ist es sozusagen von euch aus gesehen, eine gute Lösung opt in zu machen. Und dann über andere Dinge, das soll nicht automatisiert per Default entschieden, sondern da soll auch entschieden werden, aber nicht von mir, sondern von einem Kontrollgremium.
Könnte man sich ja so vorstellen. Also, mal angenommen, du bist eine Person, die ist da nicht sehr sensibel, bist vielleicht gesund, hast keine großen Issues und sagst dir im Prinzip aber kein Problem damit. Dann hast du einen einmaligen Doppter und brauchst nie wieder dich damit beschäftigen. Dann könnte man sich vorstellen, eine Person, die zum Beispiel eine schwierige Gesundheitsgeschichte hat oder sensibler ist an diesem Punkt, trifft halt vielleicht differenziertere Entscheidungen. Also nicht einmalige Doppter. War das wieder kompliziert?
Du kannst halt zum Beispiel sagen, keine Ahnung, die Daten von allen meinen Zahnarzt besuchen, finde ich irgendwie nicht so besonders sensibel. Die sollen sie immer in die Cloud schieben. Aber wenn ich beim Frauenarzt war, finde ich es vielleicht nicht so lustig, wenn sie irgendwie die Ergebnisse meines Abstrichs übermitteln.
Liebe Hörerinnen, bitte schreibt mal in die Kommentare, ob ich verrückt bin, weil ich höre hier wirklich wechselweise, dass die Leute sagen, opt in, einmal und mehr will ich nicht gefragt werden und es braucht eine reichhaltige Auswahl.
Ich komme nicht mehr hinterher. Also ich glaube, es gibt zwei Fragen in dieser Gesetzgebungsdebatte und auch mit den Abgeordneten ist die ganz grundsätzliche Frage, opt in, ja oder nein. Das ist ein großer Diskurs, den wir gerade führen.
Also nicht nur wir, sondern auch wirklich in dem Ausschuss im Parlament.
Und dann, wenn du opt in machst, kannst du ja auch immer sagen, opt in für bestimmte Daten. So, weil die werden, also ein total nerviges Konzept, das ist ein bisschen wie mit Cookie Bannern. Wenn du bei jedem Arztbesuch von deinem Arzt gefragt werden würdest, Entschuldigung.
Hier hat Cookie Banner gesagt, du war ja die Nemesis.
Da könnte man auch noch mal eine Hochvote so viel senden. Ich versuche den Knoten in deinem Kopf zu heben. Wir haben nur gesagt, wir sind pro Opt in und wir wollen auch, dass es den Politikern ins Hirn prügeln, dass das so sein sollte. Dann ist natürlich wieder die Frage, wie Opt in? Da kann es bei jedem Arztbesuch sein, dass er dich fragt und sagt, und willst du so oder du sagst von Anfang an, Nö oder jo, immer alles. Das ist ja aber losgelöst von der technischen Frage, die du vorhin gestellt hast.
Na gut, das wird technisch komplizierter.
Die basiert halt darauf.
Das ist ja noch eine technische Umsetzungsoption.
Wie die Privacy achieved wird. Die Frage hinter der Frage war ja, wie kompliziert kann man das obd innen machen?
Frag mal die Cookie Banner.
Genau. Die Frage war, könnte das obd innen so kompliziert sein, wie ein Cookie Banner?
Anyways, ich habe jetzt gelernt... Ich glaube, man kann es nicht pauschal beantworten. Du kannst nicht nur sagen, Forschung ja, nein. Wir gehen jetzt mal auf Krankheitsbilder. Menschen, die zum Beispiel Krankheiten haben, die sehr stigmatisierend in der Gesellschaft geprägt sind. Die haben wahrscheinlich ein sehr starkes Interesse, dass sie sagen, okay, meine stigmatisierende Krankheit möchte ich bitte nicht in meinen Forschungsdaten irgendwo hin kommunizieren, weil das ist stigmatisierend. Das ist aber etwas, was man anerkennen muss.
Ich unterbreche dich ungern, aber möglicherweise sind es gerade diese Personen und solche, die sagen, Forschung über diese Krankheit ist nicht zum Beispiel akzeptabel. Also, wenn es eine Möglichkeit gäbe zu sagen, hey, aber die Krankheit, die ich habe, da möchte ich das auch mit meinen Daten erforschen, könnte das durchaus sein.
Ja, aber wir können es hier jetzt auch nicht ausmachen, ob das für Menschen, die davon betroffen sind, gut oder schlecht ist, wenn sie da in die Forschung gehen. Aber wir merken, die haben da ein höheres Schutzbedürfnis, wenn sie Daten irgendwo geben würden. Und deswegen brauchen sie auch mehr Eingriffsmöglichkeiten. Es gibt Menschen, die sind gesund, die sagen, mach mit meinen Daten, was ihr wollt, das sind ganz normale Daten, ich falle nicht auf. Aber Menschen, die eine Krankheit haben, Krankheiten, die stigmatisierend in der Gesellschaft geprägt sind, die haben unter Umständen noch mal stärkeres Bedürfnis, ja oder nein, bei bestimmten Merkmalen.
Muss ich wieder fragen, ja oder nein im Sinne von pro Arztbesuch oder ja und nein im Sinne von, ich will genau vorschreiben, wer da ran darf oder wer nicht. Weil da hatte ich euch gerade so verstanden, es gibt Opt-in und das meinetwegen auch mehrfach und für alles andere gibt es ein Kontrollgremium, was den Zugang zu den Daten macht.
Also man könnte ja zum Beispiel sagen, im Sinne von, ja, ich möchte die Krebsforschung unterstützen, aber nur die Krebsforschung. Und zum Beispiel andere Themen im Bereich, wenn es um geschlechtliche Krankheiten geht, nicht. Weil das ist irgendwie für mich ein heikles Thema. Das sind ja schon mal Kriterien, die könnte man auffangen. Das heißt, du hast zwar ein Opt-in zu Krebsforschung, aber nicht zu anderen Krankheiten.
Na gut, Duilber, du müsstest eben auch nicht Leute zwingen, sich für diese Bereiche zu entscheiden. Du könntest auch sozusagen darüber eine Ebene ziehen. Ja, nein, weißt du? Und wer möchte, mit mehr auszudifferenzieren, der kann das tun. Es ist jetzt aber letztlich ein Möglichkeitenraum, der so neu an existiert. Wir können uns den vorstellen, so eine Vorstrecke gibt es auch. Aber wie es tatsächlich praktisch kommen wird, wissen wir natürlich nicht. Und wahrscheinlich wird es eher nicht so ganz kompliziert sein, denn letztlich hängt da ja ein Rattenschwanz an technischer Umsetzung dran. Und auch ein Wiederwillen dagegen, weil ja die Forschenden wissen, dass mit jeder Fragestellung, in diesem Risum oder Baum, den du da aufstellst, wird die Anzahl von den Leuten die Zustimmung geringer. Und die wollen natürlich viele Daten haben. Denn viele Daten sind halt auch aussagekräftiger in der Regel oder meistens für die Forschungsfragen.
Na gut, ich lasse das jetzt einfach mal so stehen und frage nochmal nach der LTSicherheit. Das wurde vorher so angerissen. Ist das jetzt nur die banale Forderung? Das muss schon möglichst sicher sein, wie die Daten verarbeitet werden? Oder gibt es da konkrete Baustellen, die.
Man sehen kann?
Ich glaube aktuell gibt es halt noch keine technische Lösung. Vorschreibt und es wird zu diesem Gesetz eine technische Spezifikation geben, die dann sagt, wie das ganze Ding implementiert wird. Und da ist natürlich klar, weil es um hochsensible Daten geht, muss es ein besonderes, hohes IT-Sicherheits-Schutzniveau haben.
Die praktische Implementierung wird natürlich ja nicht drinstehen. Das bleibt immer ein bisschen vage. In Deutschland gibt es das aber bereits. Das existiert ja, der Forschungsdatenzentrum besteht. Die Daten sind bereits da. Und die müssen natürlich auch ein Konzept dafür haben.
Ist der Tresorder eher so Stahl oder Papier?
Ja, Teil des Gerichtsverfahrens war natürlich auch, darüber Informationen zu bekommen.
Ach so, das stimmt. Die Frage vorher sozusagen, die Art und Weise, wie die Daten da gesichert werden, ist die transparent, also kann man quasi den Quellcode sehen?
Nö, und die lassen sich auch nicht allzu gerne in die Karten gucken. Es war schon schwierig, da überhaupt mal rauszukriegen, welche kommerziellen Dienstleister benutzen die und so. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass die begeistert waren, dass ihnen da jemand auf die Finger guckt. Und wir haben da auch ein relativ hohes Niveau. Das heißt, wir haben sofort gemerkt, da interessiert sich auch die Bundesregierung dafür, weil sie ja wissen, was daran hängt. Und da interessiert sich natürlich auch einiges aus der Europapolitik dafür, weil eben parallel...
Weil, interessiert sich an dem Gerichtsverfahren oder interessiert sich an der Art und Weise?
Also ich hätte auch nicht gedacht, dass es so viele Stellungennamen geben wird und so viele Sachverständige, die dazugezogen werden und Stellen, die dazu was sagen.
Aber wer weiß denn was?
Wir hätten nicht gedacht, dass es auf der Ebene, dass es uns jahrgerecht so dick kommt.
Aber wer weiß denn was über die IT-Sicherheit? Wissen das nur die Firmen oder weiß die Bundesregierung auch, was da passiert? Oder ist die Bundesregierung so, ja, ja, die machen das schon?
Nein, nein, die Bundesregierung ist natürlich beteiligt. Und wenn man sich das anguckt, dann sind ja auch staatliche Stellen involviert. Also zum einen das Robert-Koch-Institut, was als Vertrauensstelle wirkt. Und da ist noch ein Bundesinstitut dabei. Das sind ja sozusagen staatliche Behörden. Also die Forschungsdatenschöntung ist eine staatliche Institution. Klar.
Das beantwortet meine Frage nicht so richtig.
Okay, was war dann die Frage? Hab ich wieder mal nicht verstanden.
Die Frage war, also da liegen irgendwo Daten. Ja, viele. Genau, da liegen irgendwo viele Daten. Und die liegen in einer Infrastruktur und die liegen in irgendeiner Art von Software. Wer von den ganzen Beteiligten, die du gerade genannt hast, weiß konkret, wie diese Infrastruktur aussieht und wie die Software aussieht?
Wir haben jetzt ein paar Einblicke in diesem Gerichtsverfahren, das wussten wir vorher nicht. Aber natürlich mussten sich also insbesondere das Forschungsdatenzentrum selbst, aber auch der zuständige Ministerium auch äußern darin. Aber letztlich geht es glaube ich nicht unbedingt um so eine Form von praktischen IT-Sicherheitstest. Du willst natürlich nur bestimmte Standards erfüllen und du willst nicht unbedingt in die konkrete Implementierung gucken. Aber es war schon interessant zu wissen, welche Dienstleister und so. Offenbar hat der Vertreter des Forschungsdatenzentrums, der da ausgesagt hat, klargemacht, die unglaublich krasse Verzögerung, die jetzt stattgefunden hat, deswegen das Verfahren noch rot, hat damit zu tun, dass ein Dienstleister offenbar nicht die Leistung gebracht hat, die sie erwartet haben, qualitativ. Also die haben auch Probleme bei der technischen Umsetzung, aber die weißt du natürlich nicht im Detail. Und es gibt doch keine Vorschrift, dass sie darüber transparent sein müssen. Die haben auch so ein bisschen Ansatz Security bei Obscurity.
Normalerweise ist ja sozusagen hier am Chaosradio eine Grundforderung, das muss alles irgendwie einsehbar sein.
Natürlich, ich hab da eine gewisse Transparenzanforderung, die ist aber auch, finde ich, eher gesetzlich festzuschreiben. Zu sagen, was die da offenlegen müssen. Ja klar, also das fände ich jetzt für den europäischen Bereich natürlich genauso wichtig. Aber die haben vor allen Dingen jetzt bei Problemen bei der Abgabe der Daten. Also es gibt noch keine Form, wie sie da irgendwie einen Zugriff schaffen können. Da sind sie also doch technisch dabei.
Das heißt, verschicken sie dann Faxe, auf denen der Code ausgedruckt ist und hat Bianca wieder was zu tun?
Nee, also praktisch muss man sich so vorstellen, dass diejenigen, die dann eine Nutzungsberechtigung erhalten, also zum Beispiel ein Forschungsinstitut oder ein Unternehmen in der Gesundheitsberichterstattung oder sowas, die kriegen dann quasi ein Interface auf bestimmte Arten von Daten, also die kriegen sozusagen Zugriff, Remote, so läuft es praktisch.
Da freuen sich wahrscheinlich die Menschen von Zerforschung dann nochmal zu gucken. Ich nehme ein gewisse laissez faire, war in der Frage sozusagen, das ist doch schon eine grundlegende Sache auch, dass das irgendwie gut funktioniert.
Ich finde das absolut grundlegend, das ist auch Kern des Verfahrens, aber man muss immer noch sagen, das ist ein Gerichtsverfahren. Letztlich werden da rechtliche Fragen entschieden. Und die Frage, die hier von Berliner, in meinem Fall, von Berliner Sozialgericht entschieden wird, wird genau die sein, ob sie es vorlegen zum EGH oder nicht. Und selbstverständlich streben wir an, auf dieser Ebene zu debattieren, weil das dann Auswirkungen hat auch auf dem europäischen Gesundheitsratenraum. Denn ich glaube, diese Vorstellung, dass man hintenrum quasi ohne, dass die Leute damit zu tun haben, die die Datengeber sind, diese Daten sammeln kann und für forschungsfrei gefreigeben kann, hatte ich für falsch. Ich glaube, dass dieses Widerspruchsrecht in irgendeiner Form darin festgeschrieben werden muss. Und die Dreistigkeit, mit der sich der deutsche Gesetzgeber da irgendwie auch an den ziemlich deutlichen europarechtlichen Regelungen vorbei mogelt, finde ich schon dreist. Also, weiß ich natürlich nicht, wie das ausgeht, vor Gericht an Thora See und so. Ihr wisst ja, aber ich gehe davon aus, dass ein Teil davon so rechtlich nicht haltbar ist.
Okay, ich möchte das als gute letzte Worte stehen lassen.
Nein, eine Sache muss ich noch mal sagen. Weil ich in diesem Rechtsverfahren gelernt habe. Ich weiß nicht, ob euch das aufgefallen ist. Aber die privaten Krankenkassen sind immer raus. Und die ganze Argumentation von diesen Forschenden, die immer sagen, wir müssen alles haben. Und wenn da auch nur 0, 2% verrauscht ist, können wir nicht mehr forschen. Die fällt weg, wenn es an die Privatpatienten geht. Die sind da draus, an denen brauchen wir nicht forschen. Damit karakiert sich für mich immer dieser ganze Tohu-Wabohu, den die machen um, wir brauchen jedes Datum, sonst können wir nicht forschen.
Aber sagen die Forscher das, weil sie wissen, dass sie da eh nicht rankommen?
Fragst du mich jetzt an, was der politische Grund ist, warum die privaten Krankenkassen daran nicht beteiligt sind?
Nee, ich frage dich nach deiner Interpretation, warum die Forschenden das nicht fordern.
Vielleicht fordern sie das in diesem Gerichtshof?
Vielleicht gehen sie auch einfach den Weg des geringsten Widerstandes.
Wir haben gesundheitliche Zweiklassen, das steht darüber, warum wir hier nicht reden.
Wenn ich mich jetzt versuche, reinzusetzen in die Rolle des Forschenden, der also fordert, also keine verauschten Daten, da wäre natürlich einer meiner Kernforderungen, dass die privaten Kassen auch gezwungen sind.
Selbstverständlich.
Alleine nur für meine eigene Glaubwürdigkeit.
Das und auch, weil dir klar sein muss, dass das Sample an Leuten, also die Menschen, die in einer privaten Krankenkasse sind, auch andere Daten sind. Die sind im Schnitt gesünder und älter. Du kannst auch ganz klar sehen, dass es dadurch eine medizinische Verzerrung geht, dass du diese Millionen Datensätze nicht hast. Du kannst die ganze Argumentation, die die da immer bringen in den langen Stellungnahmen, total ad absurdum führen, wenn du sagst, private Krankenkassen hast. Aber ihr wisst, wir wollen es auch nicht immer, das Gesundheitssystem im Ganzen zu raten.
Das ist eine andere Sendung von einer anderen Zeit. Aber Anzünden scheint hier immer angebracht.
Ähm, es gibt noch viel zu tun, sagen wir mal so.
Das zählt wohl generell nicht, oder? Ich hab irgendwann aufgehört zu fragen, was die nächste Schritt ist, weil das oft schwierig ist zu sagen.
Es gibt aber welche.
Okay, danke, gleich. Meine Lieblingsfrage ist aber, wann können wir uns wieder hier im Chaosradio treffen? Wann ist es angezeigt, sich hier wieder zusammenzusetzen, weil genug Neues passiert ist? Wie viele Jahre werden da vergehen?
Oh nee, das glaub ich gar nicht mal. Ich glaub, das wird ganz schön zackig gehen.
Aha, nämlich?
Also, erst mal für den europäischen Bereich.
Also genau, wenn sie so sind, wie sie sich das vorstellen, haben wir Mitte Juli die Abstimmung von dem Bericht in den Ausschüssen.
Ziemlich schnell.
Und im September die Abstimmung im Parlament. Und Anfang des Jahres, also Anfang nächsten Jahres, den Heiligen Trilog. Na ja, dann ist ja eine Entscheidung sozusagen. Dann wissen wir, wie katastrophal das Gesetz aussieht.
Aber vielleicht wird es auch total toll.
Vielleicht wird es auch total gut, aber...
Ich liebe das. Ich liebe, dass sie nicht gesagt haben, dann gucken wir mal, wie das Gesetz aussieht, sondern dann wissen wir, welche Abstufung von katastrophal das Gesetz haben wird. Ich mag diesen Optimismus. Aber letzte Worte?
Erstmal wollte Konstanze was zu der Timeline sagen. Soll ich mal zu der Timeline sagen? Auch hier, wir haben jetzt eine gewisse Aufmerksamkeit der Presse. Was ist in 2024? Das ist meine Lieblingsfrage. EU-Wahlen. Es ist immer ein super Thema, um mit seinen Abgeordneten ins Gespräch zu kommen und auch mal vorsichtig anzumerken, dass man ein bisschen wenig damit einverstanden ist, wie das gerade mit den Gesundheitsdaten.
Um jede Subtilität zu vermeiden an dieser Stelle, du sagst den HörerInnen gerade, wenn ein EU-Wahlkampf ist, dann geht doch mal zu euren.
Nein, nein, nein. Ja, auch. Aber das wäre nur sinnvoll, wenn sich die Mache des Gesetzes so weit an den EU-Wahlkampf ran klatschen würde, dass das ein Hebel ist. Aber ganz generell kann man ja auch mit seinen Abgeordneten sprechen, wenn kein Wahlkampf ist und sagen, ich entscheide, also die Wahl ist nahe genug dran. Es würde schon das Ergebnis meiner Wahl, die ich da treffe, beeinflussen.
Wie wirst du eigentlich abstimmen?
Ja, oder mir ist es voll wichtig, dass ich selber über meine Gesundheitsdaten bestimmen kann.
Aber als EU-Auskennerin, geben sie Mühe mit dem Gesetz, um es noch vor der Wahl fertig zu machen? Oder glaubst du, es wird eher so zu sagen, ah, das ist nicht mehr unser Bier, lass mal nach der Wahl machen?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Es gibt tatsächlich eine Tendenz der Kommission dazu, kontroverse Gesetzgebungen nahe an EU-Wahlen ranzulegen, weil sie sie dann in der Regel leichter durchbekommen.
Weil ja alle wissen, dass da eine gewisse Deadline ist.
Genau, und dieses Panik-Narrativ von ohne diese Daten sterben Menschen ist natürlich sehr gut geeignet, um damit irgendwie zu polarisieren und Wähler in Panik zu versetzen. Und diese Moralpanik, die da entsteht, nutzt die Kommission häufig, um bestimmte Gesetze rein zu pipeen. Also das ist gar nicht so unnormal, dass sie das tun.
Also liebe Patientinnen, aufgemerkt auf den Jahresanfang. Ich sehe hier im Vorbereitungsdokument, ja ja liebe Chaosradio-Hörerinnen, es gibt Vorbereitungsdokumente.
Das wird wohl jeder Hörer jetzt mittlerweile wissen.
Das ist nicht so selbstverständlich. Aber hier steht noch eine Terminankündigung.
Ja, eine Terminankündigung. Ihr habt keine Terminmusik, ne? Genau, also, ganz anderes Thema, aber trotzdem ein wichtiges Thema zum Thema, ruft eure Abgeordneten an.
Wo ich sie gerade schon mal am Telefon habe.
Genau, aber es ist tatsächlich so, dass im Juni, am 14. Juni die Innenministerkonferenz in Deutschland startet. Und es ist auch nach wie vor so, dass es keine vollständig fertige Position der deutschen Bundesregierung zur Chatkontrolle gibt.
Hören Sie dazu die Chaosradio Sendung, die drei Folgen alt ist?
Ja. Und deswegen wird es eine Demo zur Innenministerkonferenz geben am 14. Juni, wo wir noch mal den Innenministerinnen der Bundesländer sehr deutlich machen werden, was das Problem ist und was wir dagegen haben. Und alle Menschen, die in Berlin sind, weitere Informationen folgen. Es ist tatsächlich relativ schwer, rauszufinden, wo die Konferenz genau stattfinden wird. Aber es gibt einen Special Guest.
Bei der Innenministerkonferenz oder auf der Demo?
Auf der Demo auch vielleicht. Aber bei der Innenministerkonferenz wird die Person, die dieses Gesetz verzapft hat, nämlich Eva Johansson, auch da sein, weil der nämlich langsam alle ihre Fälle wegstimmen und sie ein bisschen Angst hat, dass das mit der Chatkontrolle doch nicht so klappen wird. Deswegen ist es umso wichtiger, deutlich zu machen, dass die Gesellschaft ordentlich was gegen dieses Gesetz hat.
Und wem fragt man, wo, um genau rauszufinden, wann diese Demo ist?
Wir packen dann, wir haben doch Show Notes und packen da links hin.
Okay, sehr gut, so machen wir das. Dann vielen lieben Dank, dass sie hier wart und das erklärt. Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich kann nicht mich für einen optimistischen Ausflug bedanken. Ich glaube nicht, aber das wäre auch gut gewesen.
Ich hätte noch irgendwie so Timelines. Angenommen, dass dieses Thema wird verabschiedet, dann gibt es genau zwei Jahre, das zu implementieren. Nochmal was?
Okay, also Leute, jetzt müsst ihr ja also, das könnte ich euch nicht weggenommen. Erstens, meinst du jetzt Chatkontrolle oder Gesundheitsdaten? Wieso zwei Jahre?
Weil das halt typische EU-Vorgehensweise ist.
Das ist wirklich unglaublich ambitioniert.
In dem Gesetz steht drin, das soll innerhalb von zwei Jahren...
Das Gesetz tritt in Kraft und die Umsetzung muss dann in zwei Jahren in Kraft gehen.
Aber was der Unterschied ist...
Ach, da lacht ihr drüber, weil das ist total illusorisch, oder?
Das ist wirklich sehr, sehr ambitioniert. Also, das wäre echt ein Rekord. Also, ich meine, Umsetzen ist dann so fertig.
Ihr seid tief im Thema drin und könnt darüber lachen, aber alle anderen denken sich dann, da bieten die halt so ein bisschen Cloud, das wird schon ganz gut gehen.
Ich sagte immer irgendwie, Gematik und Deutschlands Gesundheitswesen und Digitalisierung, dann wissen eigentlich alle, was das für ein Dekadenprojekt ist.
Nerds lachen sich hinein. Ich glaube, was sie sagen wollen, das ist alles sehr viel schwieriger, als man glaubt.
Wir werden es begleiten.
Wir werden es begleiten. Was ist denn ein realistischer Zeitrahmen?
Na ja, also wir haben ja schon ein bisschen über den Zoo gesprochen. Da ist ja auch einfach eine Menge in den verschiedenen, unterschiedlichen Ländern an Voraussetzungen unterschiedlich. Und wir haben einen hohen Anspruch an die IT-Sicherheit. Und du hast aber gleichzeitig die ganzen Fragen der Stiftstellen. Du willst es dir auch mit hinbehalten und so weiter. Fünf?
Okay, schauen wir mal, ob wir vorher eine neue Chaosradio-Sendung hinkriegen. Die nächste Folge Dicke Bretter.
Jetzt, wir nehmen die schon übermorgen auf. Wir kommen aber mit der Produktion dann erst.
Und zum Thema? Das war auch eine goldene Brücke dafür.
Wie entstehen eigentlich diese Richtlinien und Verordnungen in Europa? Haben wir ein Beispiel der?
Und vor allen Dingen, deswegen haben wir das, das würden wir dann auch erfahren. Was ist eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen einer Richtlinie und einer Verordnung?
Das ist ja noch easy playing, wir machen das. Das wird richtig. Nee, aber das macht Spaß. Ich meine, darüber wissen viele wenig, aber das ist sicherlich interessant. Das formt unser Leben.
Wir brauchen mehr EU-Nerds.
Okay, also wenn ihr wissen wollt, was das bedeutet und warum, dann einfach die nächste Folge hören.
Also so wie uns, nicht so wie die.
Bleiben Sie in diesem Feed, bleiben Sie uns gewogen. Empfehlen Sie uns weiter. Ich will jetzt gar nicht mehr diskutieren, ob das jetzt die richtige Wahl ist. Ich sag gleich noch was, aber vorher hat Carlesi noch einen Musikwunsch?
Ja, passend zu dem ganzen Thema hier. Bianca, kannst du vielleicht erraten, wünsche ich mir natürlich Data Breach.
Von?
Systemabsturz.
Sehr gut, dann viel Spaß.
Systemabsturz ist immer gut.
Ich kann nur eine Sache sagen, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.
Die gute Fix ist dieser Data Breach.